WATCHING FOR HEADLINES.
IN THE MEANTIME, FROM LAST NIGHT
THERE WAS THIS ON FOX.
>> President Trump: I THINK
WERE GOING TO HAVE A VACCINE BY
THE END OF THE YEAR.
THE DOCTORS WILL SAY YOU
SHOULDN’T SAY THAT.
I WILL SAY WHAT I THINK.
I’VE MET WITH THE HEADS OF THESE
BIG COMPANIES, GREAT COMPANIES.
I THINK WERE GOING TO HAVE A
VACCINE MUCH SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER.
B TO ONE OF THE HEADLINES FROM
LAST NIGHT, PRESIDENT TRUMP
PREDICTING A VACCINE BY THE END
OF THE YEAR.
MEANWHILE SCO BEHIND THE COMPANY
OF A POSSIBLE TREATMENT,
REMDESIVIR, TOLD CBS NEWS THAT
DRUGS ARE THRIVING IN HOSPITALS
THIS WEEK.
ONCE A BRING IN A DIRECTOR OF
THE HARVARD GLOBAL HEALTH
INSTITUTE, DOC, NICE TO SEE YOU
AGAIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO YOU.
VACCINE BY THE END OF THE YEAR,
IS IT POSSIBLE?
>> BILL, THANKS FOR HAVING ME
BACK ON.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT, AND I THINK
WE’RE ALL GOING TO HELP.
I THINK IT’S GOING TO BE A LONG
SHOT TO GET IT BY THE END OF
THIS YEAR.
BY 2021, SOMETIME, HOPEFULLY
EARLIER ON WOULD BE GREAT.
IT’S REALLY OPTIMISTIC TO THINK
WE CAN GET IT BY JANUARY.
SPEECH I’M LOOKING AT THE
SCIENCE, IT’S BETTER THAN IT WAS
DURING THE HIV FIGHT.
BETTER THAN IT IS DURING EVEN
EBOLA THREE YEARS AGO.
WHEN YOU’VE GOT ALL HANDS ON
DECK FROM ALL THESE COUNTRIES
AROUND THE WORLD, WHY NOT
CONSIDER THE POSSIBILITY OF IT
BEING FAST-TRACK?
>> ABSOLUTELY, REMEMBER IT TAKES
YEARS TO MAKE VACCINES IN
GENERAL.
SO ANYTHING THAT’S LIKE NINE,
12, 18 MONTHS IS SUPER FAST
TRACK.
THE ONLY THING I WOULD SAY IS
WE’VE NEVER BUILT A CORONAVIRUS
VACCINE BEFORE.
THIS IS OUR FIRST TIME AS
HUMANITY.
JOY THINK WE CAN DO IT?
I DO.
ALL HANDS ON DECK.
BUT WE JUST HAVE TO PLAN FOR THE
POSSIBILITY THAT IT MAY TAKE A
LITTLE WHILE, BECAUSE WE’VE
NEVER DONE THIS BEFORE.
>> Bill: OXFORD UNIVERSITY IS
ON THIS, AS YOU KNOW, PFIZER,
JONATHAN AND JOHN THE THIN.
OXFORD SET OVER THE WEEKEND THEY
WILL KNOW IF THERE VACCINE IS
EFFECTIVE IN EARLY JUNE.
A MONTH AWAY, PRETTY FAST.
>> IT IS.
THEY’RE GETTING INTO PHASE TWO
TRIALS.
LOOK, I DON’T MEAN TO BE THE
DOWNER ON THIS, I AM THE
ENTHUSIAST.
I JUST DON’T WANT TO OVERPROMISE
AND UNDER DELIVER.
IT WOULD BE MUCH BETTER IF WE
HOPE FOR JANUARY, BUT PLANNED
FOR JUNE OR SEPTEMBER OF 2021,
AND IF WE GET SURPRISED, IT
WOULD BE AWESOME.
>> Bill: WILL TAKE THAT, IT
STRONG LANGUAGE YOU HAVE ABOUT
THE CDC, HOW COME, WHAT YOU
THINK IS GOING ON THERE?
>> I FEEL TERRIBLE, BECAUSE AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH PERSON, I’VE
ALWAYS LOVED AND ADMIRED THE
CDC, THEY HAVE JUST BEEN AWOL IN
THIS, THE ENTIRE TIME, THEIR
ADVICE HAS NOT BEEN ON TIME, AND
EVIDENCE-BASED.
THEY’RE NOT GIVING US THE DATA
WE NEED.
I THINK WE REALLY NEED TO TAKE A
HARD LOOK AT WHAT’S HAPPENING AT
THE CDC, AND WHY ARE THEY NOT
PERFORMING AS WE EXPECT THEM TO?
>> Bill: I SAW SOME OF YOUR
COMMENTS, YOU DON’T LIKE THE
LEADERSHIP IN ATLANTA, THAT’S
WHAT I TAKE AWAY FROM WHAT
YOU’RE SAYING.
>> LOOK, I DON’T KNOW WHAT’S
GOING ON, TO BE PERFECTLY
HONEST.
WHAT I CAN TELL AS THEY ARE NOT
PERFORMING.
>> Bill: THE FIRST TEST
FAILED.
>> YES, THE FIRST TEST FAILED,
THEY PUT OUT RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN SLOW.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN KEEPING UP ON
THE DATA FOR FOUR WEEKS, THEY
TOOK THE WEEKEND OFF ON UPDATING
WHAT WAS HAPPENING WITH THE
PANDEMIC.
YOU DON’T TAKE WEEKENDS OFF IN
THE MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC.
THERE BEEN A LOT OF ISSUES, AND
I DON’T UNDERSTAND WHAT’S GOING
ON, BUT WE’VE GOT TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
>> Bill: WE WILL SEE THAT,
THERE’S A REPORT FROM
SOUTH KOREA SAYS YOU CANNOT GET
IT FOR A SECOND TIME.
YOU’VE SEEN THAT STUDY, WHAT YOU
THINK?
>> LOOK, THIS IS HEADING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
WE HAVE WANTED TO BE SURE THAT
ONCE YOU’RE INFECTED AND GET
BETTER, WE WOULD LOVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU ARE IMMUNE AND YOU
CAN GET REINFECTED.
WE’VE HAD A FEW INSTANCES OF
PEOPLE TESTING POSITIVE AGAIN,
MORE AND MORE, THE EVIDENCE IS
COMING BACK, THOSE PEOPLE ARE
NOT REINFECTED, MAY BE PICKING
UP A FRAGMENT OF THE VIRUS.
HOPEFULLY, YOU REALLY DO GET
IMMUNITY AFTER YOU’VE BEEN
INFECTED.
>> Bill: LET ME TRY AND TWEEZE
ONE MORE QUESTION BACK HERE IN
THE U.S., WHAT IS YOUR FEELING
ABOUT THE REOPENING OF THE
ECONOMIES IN THESE GOVERNORS
TRYING?
>> YOU KNOW, WE ALL WANT TO
REOPEN.
I GET THE FEELING, I TOTALLY AM
SYMPATHETIC.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT’S
GUIDELINES FOR OPENING UP
AMERICA AGAIN ARE EVIDENCE-BASED
AND SCIENCE-BASED.
I WANT GOVERNORS TO USE THOSE
GUIDELINES, AND IF THEY MEET THE
GUIDELINES, I THINK THEY SHOULD
OPEN.
BUT, NOT ALL THE GOVERNORS, NOT
ALL THE STATES DO.
SOME OF THEM ARE GOING AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT’S GUIDELINES, AND
THAT MAKES ME REALLY NERVOUS.
>> Bill: DOCTOR, GOOD LUCK, I
HOPE YOU COME BACK IN A MATTER